SiC hi guys my name is grace Helbig if
you did not know now you know your life
is different now if you are a peru's or
of YouTube not a pervert on YouTube
peruse er of YouTube I mean there are a
little bit synonymous but you are a per
user of YouTube you know that nighttime
routines are a very popular type of
video on this platform and for whatever
reason all the people that post their
nighttime routines somehow have a
different routine every season I okay
cool
interesting subscribe I've posted
nighttime routines on this YouTube
channel before but like everyone else we
grow we evolve we change our nighttime
routines change in tandem with the
evolution of our person so I wanted to
show you guys my updated nighttime
routine for the fall ish time for truly
any it could be any season this could be
any season enjoy
after a long day spent shutting out the
world and avoiding any real adult
responsibilities that have been building
up for days and days I slip into
something more comfortable and buy more
comfortable I mean a men's Top Gun
flight suit costume then we continue
some further oppression before we get
into our nighttime routine consisting of
looking at the bathtub knowing you'll
never take a bath but instead throw a
group of cotton balls resembling loosely
a bath bomb into it looking at the
dishes you haven't washed looking at the
laundry you haven't finished looking at
the mail you have been open looking at
your friends books you promoted but have
not read and get a photo of the family
you have not returned the calls up
looking at the desk you should be
sitting at to get any semblance of work
done looking at this random ass pile of
clothes and wandering duffle your plans
for that you get what's going on with
the election looking at the unnecessary
amount of dog toys you continue to buy
in hopes of buying your dogs love even
though she's like looking at the device
many used to make tea before making your
own tea after all those rituals are done
and I bring my tea into bed with me I
listened to some sweet calming tunes
were gently falling asleep
[Music]
I fall asleep I'm eatin let the anxious
thoughts take over my brain and keep me
up into the early hours of the morning
cute
wow that was cute ass so there you go
there's my fall nighttime routine I hope
you guys liked it maybe you can relate
to it if you can leave me a comment down
below letting me know which area of the
routine you actually relate to and if
you like this video in general just give
it a thumbs up and subscribe to my
youtube channel by clicking this button
if you're on some sort of desktop or
laptop device if you're on mobile I'm
sorry I'm I haven't figured out how to
do that yet I know that there are
buttons I can click that allow you to
subscribe to me on mobile I just haven't
figured out yet but I'll try I mean you
see my nighttime routine is so insanely
packed that I barely Oh kind of make
videos so you're lucky to get what you
get mm-hmm
I don't know your first name
it's goose I can't pop it I didn't write
the movie